نقلت رويترز مطلع نوفمبر الماضي عن مصادر
في حماس قولها انها استعدت لحرب طويله
الامد وانها واثقه من قدرتها على استخدام
تكتيكات حرب العصابات لاحباط جيش الاحتلال
نشرت كتائب القسام يوم امس مقطع فيديو
يوثق عمليات تصنيعها بندقيه غول وحمل
الفيديو عنوان صنعنا بايدينا ما نحصد به
رؤوسكم
ا
[موسيقى]
اما عن قناصه الغول فكشفت عنها كتائب
القسام عام
2014 وكان هذا الاسم تيمنا بمطور القائد
القسمي عدنان الغول هي من عيار 14 مليمترا
ونص وبمدى قاتل يصل الى نحو 2000 متر لا
توجد معلومات دقيقه حول ما تملكه الفصائل
الفلسطينيه من قوه عسكريه لكن صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه نشرت عام
2021 تقديرات عن المخابرات الاسرائيليه
تقول ان الفصائل تملك نحو 30 الف صاروخ
بقذيفه هاون وبمد مختلفه لكن ما هي نوعيه
الصواريخ
فتبدو بمدي مختلفه وبهذا الشكل بالتحديد
بدايه القسام بمدى يصل الى 10 كيلومترات
القدس 101 بمدى 16 ر جراد او سجيل بمدى 55
م ام 75 بمدى
75 ر نصل الى الفجر تصل الى 80 بمدى 100 م
ار 160 بمدى 100
م وايضا با ام 302 بمدى 200 م واخيرا عياش
ب
25 تصل الى مدى 250 م طبعا عياش هو الاضخم
اضخم صواريخ الحركه حتى الان راسه المتفجر
يبلغ 300 كغم تخيلوا كما تملك صواريخ ارض
ارض صواريخ كورنت المضاده للدبابات الى
جانب مسيره ابابيل التي سميت ب مسيره
الزواري وتستخدم في العمليات القطريه
المباشره وتحمل الصواريخ والقنابل الصغيره
ايضا مسيره شهاب التي لديها القدره على
التخفي وتحديد المواقع اضافه الى ضرب
اهداف دقيقه كيف علقتم على قناصه الغول
والرساله التي وجهتها القسام الى جيش
الاحتلال نبدا هنا
بنبيل اذا يقول نبيل لها عده رسائل قويه
للاحتلال بان في جعبتنا المزيد لكم وبقدره
المقاومه على صنع اسلحه محليه بايديها
ننتقل الى حساب حسام يقول والله التاريخ
محتاج يتوقف شويه ويكتب بكل فخر اللي
بتعمله المقاومه وكونهم بعد 72 يوم
محاصرين من اكبر دول العالم وبطي ودباباته
الذكيه ولس صواريخهم بتوصل تل ابيب نصل
ايضا الى ايمن يقول ايمن هنا في الوقت
الذي كنا نلهو في فيه ونخوض ونلعب كان
رجال الله يعدون العده ويصنعون المجد
اخيرا نصل
الى تعليق كيلاني تقريبا دي اول حركه
مقاومه تصنع سلاحها بهذا الشكل الناس
بتعمل القناصات على المخرطه ما في اي دعم
من قوى اقليميه او امبراطوريات او اي حاجه
اما في معركه طوفان الاقصى فكشفت حماس عن
منظومات جديده استخدمتها في المعركه وم
قذيفه الياسين 105 تتكون من راس تدميريه
مزدوجه وهي ذات قدره تدميريه عاليه تستخدم
ضد الاليات المدرعه تدريع عاليا ومداها
المؤثر
150 مترا منظومه الدفاع الجوي متبر واحد
محليه الصنع استخدمت في التصدي لطائرات
الاحتلال خلال معركه طوفان الاقصى وايضا
هنا قذيفه العمل الفداء اكتسبت شهره واسعه
في طوفان الاقصى حيث يتم الصاقها على
الاليات وتدميرها من نقطه الصفر وتتميز
بقدره تدميريه عاليه